alors on va couper tout de suite court
aux suspicions oui ce chiffre de 2 % est
parfaitement exact il nous vient d'un
rapport de la tei h l'agencé technique
de l'information sur l'hospitalisation
qui a pour mission de collecter et
analyser les données relatives aux
établissements de santé c'est un peu
l'insee de l'hôpital si vous préférez
donc oui en effet en 2020 les personnes
atteintes de kobe 19 ont représenté
seulement 2% de l'ensemble des patients
hospitalisés et maintenant qu'on a dit
ça en réalité on n'a pas dit grand chose
en fait il faut aussi regarder tout un
tas d'autres chiffres premièrement en
2020 les français ont continué d'avoir
des cancers des avc des arrêts
cardiaques des appendicites des
fractures et des enfants aussi il n'y a
donc pas eu que le coc vide en revanche
les infections et inflammations
respiratoires comme cause
d'hospitalisation ont bel et bien
exploser en 2020 plus 412% c'est à dire
une multiplication par 4 c'était la 94e
cause d'hospitalisation en 2019 la
septième en 2020 et ce fameux chiffre de
2% il ne renvoie qu'à un nombre de
patients sauf qu'il faut aussi compter
avec la durée du séjour à l'hôpital le
nombre de jours de soins que requiert le
patient est justement les malades du
code vides ont été hospitalisés en
moyenne plus de 13 jours c'est plus de
deux fois plus long que la moyenne des
hospitalisations 2019 des séjours plus
longs et donc qui pèse plus sur le
système de santé et c'est encore plus
flagrant pour les soins intensifs en
2020 un jour de prise en charge en
service de réanimation sur cinq étaient
dues aux qu'ovide plus de 10 %
d'activité en plus pour les service de
réa par rapport à l'année précédente et
tous ces chiffres dont on parle ce sont
des statistiques sur l'ensemble de 2009
un lycée sur toute l'année alors que le
coe vie de 10 9 a frappé par vagues
surtout au printemps et à l'automne
c'est un peu comme si pour parler du
temps qu'il a fait hier on se contentait
de dire que la température moyenne
annuelle en france était de 15 degrés ça
n'a pas vraiment de sens pour le coc vie
de ce qu'il faut regarder c'est le
nombre de patients par mois et surtout
le poids qu'ils font peser sur le
système de santé à un moment tu es en
fonction de la durée de leur
hospitalisation et malheureusement la
tei h n'a pas publié de données aussi
précises maintenant tout ce que je viens
de vous dire ça ne constitue pas un
argument en faveur de la politique
sanitaire gouvernementale je ne vous dis
pas que les confinements les couvre-feux
les fermetures de commerces ont été des
mesures proportionnées ni même
nécessaire et encore moins que le pass
sanitaire où l'état d'urgence sont
justifiées ce n'est pas le propos ici je
vous dis simplement que ce chiffre de 2%
que l'on entend partout ne permet
clairement pas à lui seul d'émettre un
jugement éclairé